So, imagine we have a a like a music
streaming site and you want to listen to
music and you haven't ever been here
before. Um, the fact that you haven't
been to the site before is not a blocker
because your public ID you can
authenticate. It's self-referential. You
don't have to make an account and get an
email and all that stuff. The fact that
you have the private key already lets
you authenticate as definitely the owner
of that account and it's true across
every site in the world just by signing
a message. So, the way that works is you
go to the site and you say log. You
don't have an account, but you just hit
login. You don't register. You just hit
login and you see a QR code. You show
the QR code to your so that so the QR
code, right? That is the grids message.
It's just encoded in this block. You
show that to your phone. The phone goes,
oh, that's a grids message. So, I will
open Godu Mobile. And, and if you're
doing this on desktop, you do the same
thing. um you open the website that URL
like the grid's message there will be a
text version of it too. You copy that
out and you drop it into the the grids
text box on uh um guidees. What that
does, it's an instruction to pick up a
message from that site. It's a it's a
random message that's like a login
challenge. Your wallet, it doesn't
matter if it's Gajjask or Gaju Mobile,
whichever one, it says, "Hey, it wants
you to sign this message." and you sign
it. You know, once you once you say yes,
that sign message now goes back to the
site and the site goes, "Okay, we know
the public key and we know that whoever
owns whoever's in charge of that public
key definitely has the private key." So,
we create them. If they haven't been
here before, we create them a blank
account. If they have been here before,
they're just logged into their existing
account. from that point forward. Um, if
you want to do direct spins, like if you
just want to buy a thing, like I'm gonna
buy a song and download it. If they have
that for sale, you put it in the web
shop at checkout, same thing. There's a
little grids message that's asking you
to send a transaction to them. Um, that
for a website plugin that would be like
in a shop like this. If you're just
doing a straight purchase, that would be
attached to the Guad Pay back end for
the for the vendor. and Gaju Pay is
watching the chain. It knows this
transaction went through and it can tell
the website, you know, call their web
hook and say, "Hey, web shop, that guy
paid now." And it's done. That's it's
just you log in by looking at a QR code.
You pay for the thing at checkout by
looking at the same well similar uh QR
code. It's it's just that it's simple.
The first one says sign this message to
log in. The other one says, "Do you want
to pay this or not?" and he'd go, you
know, if you say yes in both cases,